-My next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actor
who you know from "Broad City."
She co-wrote and stars in
the new movie "False Positive,"
which premieres June 25th
on Hulu.
Please welcome Ilana Glazer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -Ilana Glazer ♪
♪ Let that woman live ♪
♪ Nothing can faze her ♪
♪ 'Cause she's false positive ♪
♪ Ilana Glazer ♪
♪ Don't call her insane ♪
♪ She's got some issues ♪
♪ It's more than mama brain ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Oh, my goodness, come on now.
-How does one sit?
-Yeah. You kind of sit -- Yes.
-I don't even know
how to sit pregnant.
You know what I mean?
-You can do whatever
you want to do.
-It's sort of that,
like, Kardashian,
like, end of seat thing.
[ Laughter ]
-You always sit
and have good posture, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I'm so happy. Hi, baby.
-Hi. Hi, Jimmy. Hi.
-Baby, you just got a standing
ovation on "The Tonight Show."
Not bad, huh?
-We're on "The Tonight Show."
Do you like it?
-This is so exciting.
This is your first baby.
How is it going?
How do you feel?
-I -- Okay.
So, I'm feeling really good,
but I feel a little guilty
about it, I guess.
Just 'cause I'm just like --
People are like, "I'm so sick."
I was sick for a bunch of
months, and then after that,
I was like, "This is
the coolest thing ever."
-Yeah.
-I mean, it's
the coolest thing ever.
-I'm happy.
We're all happy you're not sick.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now that I'm not puking,
I'm like, "This is really cool."
At the time, I was like,
"I'm torn."
-Yeah.
-It's so wild because the movie
that we're about to talk about
is just unbelievable timing.
You're pregnant, and the movie
is about getting pregnant.
It's bizarre.
-We filmed this
like two years ago,
and I was very much
not pregnant, and then --
[ Laughter ]
Not even a little bit pregnant.
And so, also, it was like we
were going to do festivals
and then COVID pushed it back
and then this festival
was still pushed back.
We were going to bring it out
in April.
And, like, now it's just
I'm just so pregnant,
as I am in the movie.
-It's so meant to be.
-It's actually creepy.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
If your baby is anything like
you, what do we have to expect?
-I was -- I mean, I really
loved to perform as a kid.
I was like --
[ Vocalizes ]
You know, me and my brother
would make
all these comedy videos, but --
-Oh, really?
You mean this girl
liked to perform?
[ Laughter ]
-That is 1990s Long Island dance
competition realness, okay?
-That's what I'm talking about
right there.
-We're talking Suffolk County.
-Yes!
-We're talking paying
to get into the competition.
What kind of scam is that,
you know?
That is -- That is real.
-That is so cute.
Oh, my gosh.
-Hilarious.
-I want to talk about this
because this movie
is not hilarious.
This is actually a thriller.
-Yeah. It's really disturbing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's -- It's really scary.
"False Positive" is
a psychological thriller about
how the patriarchy is
expressed through medicine,
particularly pregnancy medicine,
and it's literally scary.
-Yeah. How'd you come up
with that?
I mean, I know all comedians
are dark, but I mean --
-Yeah.
-This is a great idea,
and it's well done.
I mean, everyone in this
is great.
Justin Theroux is great.
Pierce Brosnan.
-Is he scary or is he scary?
-And the funny --
He's James Bond.
He's the best-looking dude,
the nicest dude.
-I know. He's, like,
such a lovely human
and so, so handsome that it was
like, "Is this gonna work?"
It was actually scarier
how handsome he is.
It was like,
"You're creepy, dude."
You know what I mean?
-He did such a good job, yeah.
-Ooh!
-Did you have to, like,
in between takes, go like,
"Okay, I'm acting, I'm acting.
I'm not really this creepy."
-We like --
It was, like, so built up.
You know, in comedy you get
that release where it's, like,
in the scene, you're whatever,
farting, making out with Dratch,
you know what I mean?
And you're laughing during it.
-Sure.
-Or, like, right after.
But afterwards, we'd be like --
[ Whimpering ]
Like, me and Pierce getting
the, like, "giggles" of --
You know what I mean?
Of creepiness.
It was scary.
-Well, we already kind of set up
the film, basically, right?
-Yeah.
-So I just want to show a clip.
Here's Ilana Glazer
in "False Positive."
Take a look at this one.
-Mummy brain is a real thing,
Lucy.
Prepartum depression hits about
one out of five women.
-Listen to Dr. Hindle.
You should be enjoying
this process.
-We now know that Xanax is safe
at .25 milligrams
starting with third trimester.
-So this won't affect Wendy?
-Wendy?
No. No, no.
Try and take care of yourself,
Lucy.
Hmm?
Do that for me?
-Smile, Lucy.
It actually makes you happier.
It's scientifically proven.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ilana Glazer!
"False Positive" premieres
June 25th on Hulu.
We're so happy that you came
into the studio, by the way.
-I'm so happy to be here.
-The audience loves it.
We're all so happy
that you're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy for you.
Ilana Glazer once again.